[Music]
caitlin is with us in salt lake city hi
caitlin how are you
i'm joe well how about you guys better
than we deserve what's up
awesome well my husband and i are
basically house broke um and i'm
stressing out and i don't really know
what to do
okay
how much is your house payment
it's about fourteen hundred fifty
dollars every month uh my husband works
full-time
uh earning about 54k every year
i'm full i'm home excuse me home
full-time with our two boys and we're
going to be starting homeschooling in
the fall
okay
how much debt have you got other than
the house
actually we're debt-free as soon as the
those government checks came in we paid
off the last of our debt i quit my job
in may 2020
and i've been home ever since
um
well something has to change doesn't it
his income
or that house
because you bought that house based on
you working
we bought it about
excuse me back in 2016. based on you
based on both of you working
right when your income stopped for you
to come home
that made you not be able to afford the
house
right
so either we could develop some kind of
a game plan to get his income up
substantially and quickly
or we need to move down in house
okay because his take-home pay is what
four grand uh
around there i think yeah i can't uh
you're approaching 50 of his take-home
pay is your house payment that's not
sustainable
right
it's stressing you yeah well you don't
have any room
what's his i can tell the distress in
your voice caitlyn um what's his feeling
with everything does he feel the same
sense of urgency and stress and weight
that you're feeling
yes like he he does not like it um but
we
don't know
i mean we want god to be in everything
that we're doing we just don't know what
that looks like specifically
i can help you with that the blessings
of the lord
have no sorrow added to them
so we can safely say this house is not a
blessing
it has been for some time
it has sorrow added to it
it has sorrow added to it
by definition
biblically
when you have sorrow added to something
it is not a blessing from god
that's true
by definition now it would it could have
been a blessing earlier when you had
both incomes coming in and it was a
reasonable house payment as a percentage
of your take-home pay
but the past is the past you all have
made other decisions now
and so you you know there's three
possible options because the math is not
going to change until you change it
you're going to go back to work he or
he's going to increase his income
dramatically doing something different
or you're going to sell the house
what's he do for a living
she's a team leader at a financial
company
a team leader at a financial company
makes 50 grand
yeah but he's a manager of
the
agents and teams and stuff
of the what
he's a team leader of about 15 people
um
agents that take calls for the financial
company
okay
all right how long have you been doing
that
um
10 years
well there has been a dramatic shift in
employment in the marketplace in the
past two years
and what people and what people are
making
okay now not everyone has experienced
wage increase because the overall wages
have only increased about five and a
half percent but we've seen entire
sectors
of of the
of the workplace their incomes double
for instance developers and programmers
okay software engineers
they're they've gone a lot of them have
gone from 100k to 200k
depending on the category that they're
in and what their skill level is as an
example
okay and there's other stuff out there
plenty i mean entry-level stuff has gone
from ten dollars to twenty dollars and
in some cases to thirty dollars an hour
and it sounds like your husband has is a
dead end thing here and he may need to
rethink what he's doing
this might be his wake-up call on his
career path
and so i mean if he could be on on a
career path that says hey when i take
this job and then i do this thing i get
this raise and i do that thing i get
that raised
and you can see your way through this in
a year or two or three then you can hold
your breath and get out of it but you
can't hold your breath forever
eventually you're gonna drown
right
i i you know
you guys like the house i can tell by
the way you're defending it
it's not so much i liked it it just gave
my my mom a place to stay after my dad
passed away they didn't have their
financial things together so they didn't
have any retirement
and so that's why
i feel like that was kind of a god
moment that now i feel like it's not
yeah
i think it's okay it was then and it's
not now is she still with you kaitlyn
she's still living with you guys
yes
okay so moving also means
um moving her moving her or finding a
place for like i mean it's that it's
more than a discussion than just your
nuclear family
right
yeah there's a lot going on here kiddo
so what i would if i were in your shoes
what would i do okay i would set myself
a deadline that says i have a new career
path
that i can see light at the end of the
tunnel for if i'm your husband
that allows us to afford this house
by the end of the year
i'm going to give myself four to six
months
and if i don't have that new career path
by spring in underway i'm going to sell
the house because i'm not going to sit
here in denial and act like this is okay
because it's not okay it's killing y'all
now you can survive it for a short
period of time
a year maybe whatever like that well she
quit her job in 2020 so it's been two
years they're not surviving they're
they're no no but i'm just saying she's
been feeling it for a while yeah yeah so
i'm gonna send you ken coleman's book uh
from paycheck to purpose
and i want your husband to jump on the
website i tell you what i'm also gonna
send him the assessment and let him take
the assessment on to send him in a
direction
of some ways and things he could go do
things he can look at but i want him to
uh
change horses
i don't think he's being paid very well
and uh 50k is okay for some things but i
think he can do better and if he can do
better you can keep this house but if he
can't
or won't
then you can't keep the house because
you're not going to be able to keep it
long term something's going to blow up
here